Speaker 1: All right. Now, I know that this is
not the most important story going on right now,
but I did want to take a little break from just
the heavy politics stuff we've been doing for
a bit and let you know about something new
that's going on. As many of you know, we have
struggled at the show over time on different
platforms. We've had 99.8% demonetization on
YouTube during Apocalypse 1.0, about 60% demanded
a monetization on YouTube during Apocalypse 2.0.
If you don't remember these incidents, the
details are less important than knowing
that at any point there are problems on different
platforms. On TikTok, we have had suspensions for
so-called COVID disinformation, which was
us debunking COVID disinformation. We had a
period of about three weeks where we lost all
of our revenue on Facebook for wrongly being
labeled COVID disinformation. Okay, we've had all
these different things. We are now experiencing
similar issues on Instagram, as many of you know,
roughly 100,000 of you who follow us on Instagram,
we publish our content to Instagram. It's another
platform with a ton of users and we want to be
there. We learned last week that on Instagram our
account is being limited because of supposedly
false content about COVID or vaccines that we
have disseminated. And in fact, for most users,
if you try to mention The David Pakman Show, which
is us on Instagram, you get a message which says
can't mention David Pakman show because they
have repeatedly posted content that goes against
community guidelines on false content about COVID
19 or vaccines. What on earth? How could this
possibly be? I went and looked well. What are
the clips that are supposedly false information
about COVID or vaccines? There's only two such
clips that were removed. One is where we covered
that. Um, Dr. Fauci wanted a fox host fired
over a kill shot comment. There was a Fox host
who talked about Fauci and used the phrase kill
shot, which suggests violence against Dr. Fauci.
We covered that. And the clip was removed.
The only other clip that we have had removed
by Instagram is one in which we covered. We
simply posted a sort of political cartoon about
the reaction to prior tragedies Pearl Harbor, 911
and then the number of people dying from COVID,
which is well, well, well, higher. And how for
many people, there's no reaction whatsoever.
That was also removed and flagged as spreading
COVID disinformation. It was actually saying,
we're not taking COVID nearly seriously
enough. Can you imagine? I looked up,
what is the Instagram policy on condemning COVID
disinformation or debunking COVID disinformation?
And very clearly the policy is we
allow content shared to condemn
or to debunk. We condemned a Fox host using
the term kill shot talking about Dr. Fauci.
We condemned the lack of care from so many in
the United States about what at the time was 3200
people a day dying of COVID. And we are now being
limited on Instagram because we are spreading
COVID or vaccine disinformation. Now, you would
say, well, there's got to be an appeals process,
David. You've got to be able to appeal this.
There is. But you can only appeal this ruling
if each of these decisions has a case number
attached to it, which ours do not. So we quite
literally cannot appeal an insane decision. Now,
I now know a lot of people say, oh, but David,
this is the censorship you've been advocating
for. No, it's not that. That's not true.
I have been saying these companies can have terms
of service. And if I agree to the terms of service
and I abide by the terms of service, then there
shouldn't be any issue. The terms of service are
being misapplied. We obviously aren't spreading
COVID disinformation or vaccine disinformation.
So if you work at Metta, Facebook, Instagram
and you think you can help with this,
please get in touch with us. Info at David Pakman
dot com. I would very much appreciate it. When we
had an issue on Facebook, about a dozen people in
the audience who work at Facebook got in touch and
we were able to get it resolved. It took almost
a month, but we were able to get it resolved.
If you think this is something you might
be able to help with, please get in touch
info at David Pakman dot com. We just want to
keep publishing our stuff. That that's all.
It's that we clearly have been caught up in some
kind of dragnet. That's that's more conspiratorial
than it is. Clearly, some kind of algorithm
has misidentified our content. That's all.
And we would appreciate help with
that. And of course, as always,
as we've said before, every revenue source we
have other than our website memberships has been
cut at some point in the past. It's happened
with Instagram, Facebook, Twitter, of course,
TikTok, YouTube, all of it. So the best insulator
for us so that when these things happen,
they don't really affect our revenues is to get a
membership on our website, join Pacman dot com and
you can do that. You can use the coupon code,
big voting 22 sort of a coupon code to encourage
voting and participation in the midterms. Big
voting 22 And you can use that to sign up at join
PAC Mint.com. And it really it really does do a
lot and it helps to at least partially protect us
from when things like this happen. So let me
know if you work at Metta Facebook Instagram
info at David Pakman dot com if you
think you might be able to help.